You were saying you've turned a corner in the reading of Hegel.
Well, okay. So, I mean, I'll give you a little bit of the process just to contextualize.
But as I told you, I'm writing this thing right now that's going to be probably, I think, like the first chapter or chapter-ishy thing for the book on genealogy and the master-slave and blah, blah, blah.
And so, of course, I just ended up, I think it's probably just because obviously Hegel's been on my mind, but it's like, you know, I just kind of want to pursue this.
Well, some people have written about it, right? Like the relationship between Hegel's version of master-slave and Nietzsche's version of master-slave.
And the thing that became very clear to me reading, and by the way, not a lot of people have written about it, which is something that actually surprised me a great deal.
Like there's not a ton of stuff there, or maybe there's chunks of chapters somewhere that I didn't find, but in terms of articles or certainly not books, like, I mean, there was a very limited, I mean, like 10 things, like not a whole lot of stuff.
And so I went through those things.
And the thing that became pretty clear to me is that Deleuze is the guy who installs this notion of an antagonism between Hegel and Nietzsche.
Right.
And so that just, you know, that made me pause a little bit, like, because, like, Walter Kaufmann and other, you know, Walter Kaufmann is the big Nietzsche translator and also early, you know, sort of existentialist-oriented writer on Nietzsche.
And he sees, you know, a kind of, and most did prior to Deleuze see, like, hey, these are very similar thinkers.
And the phrase that I really, really liked to describe Hegel and Nietzsche both was that they're both dialectical monists, which I like that phrase.
Like, it's a monistic word, but now I would not describe Nietzsche as a dialectical monist, but I'd describe him as an agonistic monist.
Right.
So it's, they're not terribly far afield from that agonistic or dialectical distinction.
So in any case, it's like, Deleuze's book is that Nietzsche and Philosophy, 1962, like, that's the moment where this argument began of, like, you know, the Deleuzians don't like Hegel or whatever.
Right.
And I also remembered from my last reading, the last time that I read Nietzsche and Philosophy, which I can't remember, but it's not too long ago.
That I was really, I really accentuated.
Didn't we do it this summer?
Did we do it this summer?
Yeah.
We did that chapter, yeah.
The last chapter.
Right, right.
So in that last chapter, I mean, and something that I kind of emphasized a lot in my reading was that he both establishes them as opposites and undercuts the establishing of opposition.
Right, like, and that's the part that is totally missing from the reception, the undercutting of the opposition.
So, because, I mean, Deleuze says very, very clearly, like, from the perspective of dialectics, Hegel and Nietzsche are opposites.
But from the perspective of Nietzsche, they're just different.
Right.
I mean, you know, in other words, that opposition is the slave way of thinking, you know, for Deleuze.
So, the idea that Deleuze simply installs an opposition between Hegel, which is the sort of received story.
Deleuze is the guy.
He installs an opposition.
But that's way, way too simplistic.
And it really just kind of got me, like, well, I would say the easiest way of saying it is I think I started reading Hegel a little more sympathetically.
Yeah.
And, like I said, a little bit less suspiciously.
I still have, I don't think that I've lost the reservations that I've had as we've talked throughout.
But I really see what he's doing now.
Like, I really see it as committed to process thinking.
You know, and that's all, and the section that we read for today is just so clear on that.
Like, his beef with math is entirely that there's no process.
Right.
It's concerned with sort of results and proof, you know.
And it just eliminates the movement of the thing.
Now, again, I still have these issues with, like, its own and the necessity of the movement coming from inside itself and the metaphorics of that.
But I do think that, you know, following Zizek, it's also been reading the Malibu and Zizek.
But there are ways of undermining, I mean, and it's not hard.
Or there are ways of reading Hegel against the grain in that sense.
And it's not difficult to do when he says, you know, the movement comes from within itself.
It's easy to show how that's not really within itself, that the within itself is already a sort of result of an extrinsic or external force.
So, nevertheless, like, the result for me has simply been, like, you know, I just feel I'm reading it way more sympathetically than I was over the last, you know, over the summer when we were doing the majority of these videos.
Well, yeah, the critique of math in this section, parts of it, maybe just because I've been trying to sort of synthesize the Deleuzian and the Hegelian positions, if you want to call them that.
But I thought there were moments where Hegel's focus on contingency and becoming, even if the dynamics of that becoming are different and even crucially different from Deleuze's, there were portions where it's like, that could have been a Deleuze sentence here and there.
Yeah, I agree.
With the way he's confronting the representationalism that's sort of inherent to math.
And Kant's version.
And then Kant, and then offering the alternative in its nation form there.
I don't know, it didn't read to me as, like, anti-Deleuzian in any way.
Yeah, no.
Yeah.
No.
I think you can read him generously, too, on the sort of inside-outside distinction as well.
Because, I mean, the problem with math for him is that it creates a bunch of equations, but no particular, like, because an equation is always a resting place, there is nothing about that dynamic.
There's no essential inequality or difference that leads to its self-transformation.
And so, you know, I don't think that you need to read a stark binary between the inside and the outside to get at the kind of imminent self-overcoming that he's talking about.
Which is to say, like, which is to say that there cannot be an inside, a pure inside at all, because that would be an equation.
Ultimately, it is math that creates both the pure inside as the equation and then the pure outside that has to put one equation in relationship to another one.
Right, yeah.
And, I mean, you bring this, you just brought this up, but that was most striking to me was Hegel on equality sounds just like Nietzsche on equality.
Right, I mean, they really, like, these concepts, they're static concepts, they don't, or rather they're not concepts for Hegel because that would be, you know, they're not notions.
But, yeah.
But, nevertheless, like, it's their antagonism or frustration with the idea of equality, they both share it.
Now, there's a huge difference because, for Hegel, it has to get to opposition in order for it to be not equality.
And that's not true for Nietzsche, right?
Like, so, in other words, that's where difference multiplicity, I still think, is the non-systematic response to this.
But, still, in terms of the thinking of equality, they both are deeply skeptical of it as a founding concept for math.
I'm on 46, paragraph 46, towards the bottom, and, yeah, again, we have the slightly different translations.
But, he goes, the principle of magnitude, or the principle of the conceptless difference, and the principle of equality, or that of abstract, lifeless unity, are incapable of dealing with that pure restlessness of life and its absolute difference.
And, to me, again, like, he complicates it and he gets into the more phenomenological determinations later, but that, the pure restlessness of life and its absolute difference, that, to me, sounds like a Nietzschean or a Deleuzian sentiment there.
Totally.
Like, you could have cut that right out of either of them.
And, that basic critique of representationalism there, to me, is, like, I don't know, it just seems directly related to Deleuze's critique of the same thing, in both What Is Philosophy? and, kind of, in the Nietzsche and Philosophy book, as well.
Yeah, I mean, you know, what's translated here is the notion is the concept, right, I mean, if that's the big riff, right, like, that's the word that we would normally use.
I mean, I think that you're spot on, right, it's the reason there, that the concept in early, in Difference in Repetition, the concept is bad, right, the concept is the form of representation.
But, What Is Philosophy?, I think that you're spot on, like, that's where the concept is the sort of self, not, again, you have to be careful with all these words, but these self-moving, self-transformative entity, you know, and that's what it sounds like here.
I mean, it's, like, What Is Philosophy?'s, thinking of the concept, is frickin' Hegel's concept of the concept.
Exactly, well, the concept in Hegel here is attentive to that difference, whereas in math, the lifeless concept is just merely applied to life, it's a lifeless unity, right, so those delineations between,
now, I don't know how useful it is, sorry, I might be jumping ahead a little bit, but, to, like, name people, we've done, we've tried to do this a few times, like, is Descartes a target here?
Like, is rationalism sort of a name for this mathematical thinking?
I mean, it doesn't really matter, because I know that he goes through all these targets in the preface.
He kind of starts with empiricism, I think, moves through Spinoza, who's a weird, I don't even really know how to label him, and now we're on math.
And I'm just, I was wondering, we don't have to answer this right now, but, like, how each of those targets relate to each other?
Because you usually think of empiricism as being the opposite, or a completely different approach from math, right?
Or, like, from rationalism, at least from their inception.
But, uh, he seems to...
You'd be moving back in time to go to Descartes, maybe Leibniz would be a little bit...
Right, right. Well, I guess, and Kant is explicitly named soon after this.
Yeah.
So, um, but it was just, it was just interesting to me, because I thought about this in a seminar paper a while ago, and I think probably a bunch of people have written this, but, like, the opposition between the empiricist movement and the rationalist movement during that time period, they were directly opposed to each other, right?
And one of them is explicitly inductive, right?
Empiricism is the sort of more humble approach, right, where you don't start with a theory, you start with observation and experimentation and then derive a theory from that, whereas Descartes' rationalism applies a theory first and then, you know, observes matter after that.
But to me, it's like they're both confronting and kind of suppressing the same, the problem that Hegel's trying to articulate, which is the movement of conceptuality itself.
Like, that's what they're both alighting in those paradoxes.
Because they're both looking for propositional truth, right?
Right, right.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
I was just going to say, John, I wanted to speak a little bit to your hesitancy on the inside-outside dichotomy, where you're like, you have to be careful about this whole self-moving thing.
And I think there's maybe a helpful way of nuancing between two notions of the inside or of imminence, right?
Because, you know, if we're thinking in the Aristotelian tradition or, like, the Platonic tradition of, like, why something that is self-moving is somehow simply better than things that are not moving, it's because there is, like, that self-moving becomes a property of a stabilized thing, right?
So, you know, the self-moving thing, like the soul or whatever else, that is, it maintains its integrity through its movement, right?
And part of, and it's equally important that it self-moves and that it maintains its integrity as it moves.
But the second notion of self-movement, like, takes on a notion of the self that is already punctured, that is already sort of folded between the inside and the outside.
So for that self-movement, it is not just the displacement of something that has, that maintains its integrity, but it is reconstituted, its movement is its own reconstitution, which means that it is already opened up to the outside.
And I think that the problem, the beef that Hegel has here, I think I'm just now re-articulating what I said before, but the problem that Hegel has with the mathematical or propositional truth to begin with is that because it's closed off, because it deals with, like, it does maintain its integrity, it can't self-transform, right?
It can't have no self-movement, because self-movement would necessarily lead to its own transformation.
It is too impregnable, as it were.
Right.
Well, there's no room for the self in this form of mathematics, right?
There's not even, like, it almost has to be removed for that kind of thinking to work.
And this is something that I keep running up against when I try to think about both, like, traditional Newtonian physics and math and stuff like this, because the issue with math is not math in itself, like, or its function.
Like, it works, right?
Like, it has functions in the world, and it works.
And Newtonian physics is the same thing.
I mean, you can build stuff with that kind of non-theoretical or non-quantum version of physics.
The issue seems to be, maybe this is reductive, but for Hegel is that it doesn't simply rest at its function, right?
So it's functional, it works in the world to an extent, but it wants to also contain truth about the world.
Yeah, it's the question of math status.
Right, right.
So when it becomes a philosophy, which it always already was, that's when it becomes problematic, because it's, like, there's an arrogance to it.
And so when that kind of representationalist thinking infiltrates all thinking to some extent, right, like, in terms of Heidegger's critique of, like, humanism and representationalism, that's when you encounter, like, political and ethical problems, right?
I would even push that further, that Hegel has a problem with the functional notion of mathematics as well, precisely because math can't function, right?
Math can only represent itself.
It only, like, you know, take whatever mathematical formula, and it only takes itself as its object.
That to then take a mathematical formula, like, a series of mathematical formulas and apply it to a ravine where I want to build the bridge is now a non-mathematical application of mathematical equations.
Because, like, you know, this is what he's going on.
Whenever he's talking about magnitude and space and times, like, look, math doesn't take the world as its object.
It takes an abstracted notion of time and space and then differentiates orders of magnitude within that, right?
And so that's why, like, if you actually were able to set math out into the world, it would undo itself and become something else.
The math, this is what I mean by the self, not, like, a subjective human psyche, but, like, the self-same proposition.
You know, E equals mc squared is a self-contained entity that cannot refer to anything beyond itself.
Right.
Well, I guess I'm conflating, like, math in itself and then in its practical application.
I suppose I was taking for granted that math is always sort of, like, it's loosely – because with physics, like, right, you're applying theorems,
but there's also a lot of experimentation and observation that accounts for that contingency that math can't account for, right?
So there's always the combination in engineering whatever with the, like, the sort of abstract a priori theorems
and then their practical application and then working them out in physical space.
Does that make any sense?
So when I was saying, like, that math works, I think I was just, like, taking for granted that it's always, like,
sort of massaged in a way in its practical application.
Well, and he says – there's one point where he makes a comment like that is that, you know,
you could even add in a little bit of contingency and get something better.
This method – and he's talking here about math.
This is in paragraph 48.
You don't have to go to it because it's just an incidental comment.
But it's peculiar to mathematics, yada, yada.
This method in a looser form, i.e. more blended with the arbitrary and the accidental,
may retain its place as in conversation or in a piece of historical knowledge designed rather to satisfy curiosity
than to produce knowledge, which is what a preface amounts to, right?
Like, in other words, like, you could – you can throw some contingency into mathematics
and have it be more – have it be functional in the terms that we're talking about.
Do you guys know if someone's written a book on math and philosophy?
Like, you know, like –
Oh, there's a whole era.
Not an expert book, but, I mean, like an introduction because it just seems to me like the –
I mean, it's been a troubled relationship since Plato, right?
Like, I mean, we had the slave drawing the diagram in the sand, you know, that that relationship is one.
I mean, here it's being made explicit, but, I mean – and it is this idea of the claim to universality, right?
Like, that math reveals something called truths that are absolute and everywhere, like 180 degrees in a triangle, you know?
I mean, those sorts of things.
And that has often, and in many places, been the aspiration of philosophy.
Right.
Is to reveal those always and for everywhere truths for some philosophers.
Now, again, I mean, to me, what you were saying about inside, outside in the previous part of the conversation, Nathaniel, is, like, would be so much easier if you just added in perspectivism.
You know, if you just said, like, from the perspective of, you know, the entity, it looks like it's self-moved.
From the perspective of the exterior, it looks – you know what I mean?
Like, if you just added in different – that's what Nietzsche does, is that it's just – and so, you know, truth is not – I mean, in this sense, truth.
This is where – I mean, interestingly enough, while the thinking might have lots of overlap, this is a thinking that is still totally dedicated to truth in ways that Nietzsche's is a total questioning of the viability of truth or the usefulness or the – you know, and that's a major – because to me, I still think that Deleuze's – I mean, I'm still invested in Deleuze's interest.
Where it's like, look, there's something about the tone or, in my terms of style, that negation brings with it.
And I think that's getting kind of close to what that tone is here, is that systematic drive towards truth is still very much a part of this discourse, even if the thinking has very similar contents.
You know?
Right, right.
For Nietzsche, there's no – there's no truth.
Like, we're not going to get a better understanding.
It's not like mathematical knowledge is lesser – I mean, for Hegel, mathematical knowledge is lesser knowledge for all of the reasons that we've been talking about.
You know, and it does not reach the level of philosophical knowledge because it's not – it's not truth in the, you know, important way.
Right.
Well, it doesn't – I mean, in really simple terms, it just doesn't incorporate the movement of the concept into the system.
And so the really common, easy critique of math that any, like, eighth grader could ascertain is here, where it's like math is too abstract.
Like, I don't know what to do with it.
It doesn't seem to be attached to the world in any way.
So you do an equation.
You're like, how does this relate to life in any real way?
You see that here, but the slightly more important twist, I think, is Hegel's actually saying it's not only too abstract, it's also not abstract enough.
Not abstract enough.
In the sense that it's not attentive to its movement of abstraction.
So that's when you take the step from the understanding, which is that violent, abstracting force, which is the motor of mathematics or that version of rationalism.
And then you start – it's just a simple shift in perspective where you start, like, just recognizing that movement.
And so you incorporate that movement into the system as opposed to just simply suppressing it.
Right.
Which I think is what he's calling for, yeah.
I want to ask you guys – I mean, one of the big questions that I have in this passage – like, I don't know if this goes too far into 37 – page 37, sorry, like, paragraph 59.
But, well, there's some of it earlier.
The notion of the – okay, so, like, if we look at, for instance, paragraph 53, section 53,
which for us is divided into two really big, long paragraphs, the second one beginning Nathaniel on page 32 there, with even when the specific determinants – say one like Magnus, is it self-concrete or real – the understanding degrades it into something lifeless.
So, and what I'm raising into question here is the function of the understanding, because in this passage, the understanding seems like it's the thing that rigidifies, right?
Which I read is like, okay, so here's what kind of understanding as a faculty, right?
As a faculty, it's a faculty that suppresses movement, right?
That sort of isolates out.
So, the understanding degrades it into something lifeless.
And yet in other places, I feel like the understanding is precisely the thing that's necessary to, you know, to get at the notion.
And so, I just found this – it was just a question, you know, like a little bit above that.
The understanding in its pigeonholing process keeps the necessity and the notion of the content to itself, right?
So, the understanding is that is sort of what I would call like that which taxonomizes, right?
Like that which puts things into a grid and which, again, is a necessary part of the process of recognizing that there is a grid and that one is gridifying, you know, things.
So, I mean, maybe I'm answering my own question, I guess, is that – but it's – so at moments, the understanding seems like it's this delimiting force.
And then other moments, it seems like it's this undelimiting force.
It's that which is putting things into motion, I guess.
So, that was just a question.
But it seems there seems to be two movements of understanding.
And this – I mean, this seems to be pretty consistent for a while.
And what we just read today, for today, think about when he's talking about the triangle and he's like, look, the first movement of the understanding –
you know, like you start with the simplicity – to bring this back out to the general more – to the preface more generally.
He always begins with one version of the simplicity that then needs to be differentiated and taxonomized and then brought back to a second simplicity, right?
And he sort of localizes that example with the triangles, understanding, you know, the Euclidean relationships of the right triangle.
It's like that first motion of the understanding breaks it up into these discrete parts.
And those parts do not refer to the triangle but refer to other figures like, you know, a right angle and squares and whatever else.
And then it's only once you're able to put those parts back together, which is the second movement of understanding, that you have the notion of the right triangle as a living concept, as a living truth.
And this is before he goes into just wholesale critiquing mathematics.
And so when I read a sentence like that, you know, that the understanding degrades it into something lifeless, I immediately think that this is that first movement of the understanding,
which has to take the concept like magnetism and then it has to separate it from everything else in order to be able to figure out the other component parts before it gets put all back together again into a second simplicity.
Yeah, and this is one of the tricky things for me, and it's not explicitly laid out in this section, I don't think,
but the understanding, sort of like Foucault's notion of power, it's only functional if it's basically unnoticed.
So like, sort of with sense certainty, right, like, in order to perceive your world and identify objects and identify yourself within the world,
that process of sensuality, I don't even know what to call it, sensuality, sense certainty, has to be masked somehow.
So it has to sort of run smoothly, and you can't be consciously aware of it.
That, to me, is part and parcel of also the function of the understanding, if you can even separate that,
from sense certainty.
So, the weird thing for me is that, for Hegel, like you were just saying, John, like, the understanding is both, like, sort of the enemy and the savior.
Yeah, which is appropriate, I mean, that's appropriate.
Right, and you have to hold both of those kind of in mind, I mean, that's kind of the movement of the dialectic, where, previously in the preface he says,
the understanding is like the most spectacular feat of humanity.
That's right.
That's what allows us to taxonomize and whatever, appropriate the world and all that.
But here, it's the explicit enemy.
You have to sublate it somehow, not for a higher form of thinking, but you simply have to take it into account, which is precisely what it doesn't allow.
The understanding doesn't allow you to take it into account.
So, how do we get to, like, the next step, which is reason or self-consciousness, which is, like, the good thing for Hegel?
It's still a little confusing for me, but I don't know.
No, I think you're right, and I think, you know, in that sense it reads, you know, it reads more like Nietzsche, where Nietzsche doesn't mark his contradictions and doesn't say a different aspect of the understanding, does it?
He just, you know, like, he leaves that to the reader to either get it wrong or whatever, but it's like, you know, eight pages later after you said this, you know, this thing is noble, you're like, nobility is for morons, right?
It's like, and as we know, and as is confirmed in my rereading of, you know, the scholarship linking the two, everybody thinks that Nietzsche has said that the noble is good, I don't mean that in the good, bad, good, evil, but, like, the noble is better than the slave, and it's like, holy fuck, how can you read that and just ignore the passages where he says, this is what made man interesting, man would have been too stupid of a species without, you know, like, but they do, right?
Like, they just ignore or miss those places where it's like, look, the noble is not the good guy here, not simply the good guy, right?
Well, there's so much more nuance.
So that's where they're similar.
Yeah, there's so much more nuance in all of these thinkers.
Like, the issue for me that I've, after this, we did, like, you know, six, seven of these podcasts, I was just trying to basically reconcile some of these positions with each other, because nobody seems to want to do that.
Like, I mean, Deleuze was super confrontational against Hegel, which I get sort of served its purpose, and then all of the followers of each of these movements are so polemical against the different versions of this.
Like, you get, they've labeled it affirmationism, which is sort of a jibe, usually, at, like, Deleuze and Nietzsche, and then you have the dialecticians, or the people on team negation.
And it's like, I don't think any of these thinkers worked in those categories that strictly.
Or at least, their conceptual delineations offer way more than simply, I'm team affirmation.
I mean, my whole thing, in terms of the Deleuze book, was, like, with active force, like, there's no such thing as active force.
That's my line on reading the thing.
There can't be.
Otherwise, it doesn't make sense.
And I would say the same thing about affirmation.
There's no such thing as affirmation.
It's not a thing that is distinct from negation.
Like, there can't be.
Otherwise, that is the negated version of affirmation that makes it into a team process.
But, I mean, the thing that's frustrating for me is, like, this has been a problem for me for a long time.
And, obviously, in my book, I mean, if you just, even a cursory reading of it would say, look, he doesn't hate negation.
He's just interested in something else.
And that's how I felt about it.
And I had a difficult time.
I mean, that was 20 years ago, for fuck's sake.
Like, negotiating, like, trying to figure out how to articulate what I'm doing that's not the same as negation, but neither is it simply different from it.
Like, I had a hard time with that.
There's long passages in that book where I struggle with it.
And I'm fucking still struggling with it.
Right?
We're still, we're doing this thing.
So this idea that I'm team affirmation is just like, that's just, that's just lazy.
No, it's silly.
It's silly.
But you can see why people are, like, willing to make those jumps.
Not because of your work lends it to that, but because there are these camps, like, including your work, but, like, besides that, with Barad and people out in, like, other fields.
People latch on to these kind of movements, and it's easy for them.
So, like, let's say negation has been kind of thrown to the side for the past decade or something, or maybe even two decades.
Now, it's time to save negation.
And this is what Benjamin Noys does.
It's like, negation is actually the key to an ethical world.
And it's like, man, did you read Hegel?
Did you ever actually read Hegel?
Because I don't think that was ever explicit.
That's where, see, that's where I would argue, if you want to talk about the movement of historical change, it looks and smells like a dialectic that doesn't sublate at all, right?
Like, there's no aufgehoben element to it.
It's just like, yes, no, yes, no, yes, no, yes, no, yes, no.
You're like, what the fuck?
So that's the change we get in history is just like, yes, no, no, yes, yes, no.
It's just a lot of chaos, you know?
Yeah, well, it's just, but it's just a non-engagement, right?
It's not, there's, I mean, if, the problem is there's not enough aufhebening, which would be raising it and, you know, maintaining the distinctions and suspending the differences between them.
It's like, oh, like in the actual discourse, yeah, too.
Right, like, where's the fucking off-haben?
Like, I'm waiting for some aufhebens to happen.
It just seems like it's, yes, no, yes, no.
It doesn't seem like we're able to do many aufhebens in scholarship.
Right.
It's pretty tough, yeah.
So I just, in the History of Rhetoric class, I just gave a midterm, and one of the essay questions was basically like,
and all, so I had them read Gorgias' Encomium of Helen, Plato's Gorgias, Augustine's De Magistro, and the, like, chunks of Book 4 on Christian Doctrine, and then chunks of Bacon's on the Advancement of Learning, and the Novum Organum.
Like, one of the questions, like, one of the consistent themes that we find in all of these texts, or most of these texts, is a sort of an anxiety about a supposedly, like, world of falsity or appearance or, like, surface simulacrum, and then the sort of the true world that it hides.
And we get these in a number of figures, like, you know, the semblance art distinction that Plato makes, or the signifier-signified distinction that Augustine makes, or, like, the world, the scientific world as it really is, and the sort of, like, mystery of, or the obfuscating power of language.
And rhetoric is always sort of, like, you know, at the center of this.
Right.
And what I kind of realized in articulating this question and imagining responses and reading them is, it really does just seem like, yeah, there's no sublation.
It's just like, you know, Gorgias basically claims that language, there is no distinction that language produces all of these, like, all of these effects on one on others.
Plato's like, this is mere semblance, it's terrible.
Plato, Augustine, and Bacon are all like, you know, this is pure semblance, and either you can use it to reveal the truth, or you can use it to obscure it.
But that dichotomy, there's, like, there's no sublation between them.
There's no sublation.
But that's where it's cool when on Hegel, this is paragraph 47, and it speaks to that perfectly.
Like, this, I mean, I swear to God, this is a sentence out of Being and Time.
Like, I mean, I think it might actually be.
Appearance is the arising and passing away that does not itself arise and pass away, but is in and of itself and constitutes the actuality and the movement and the life of truth.
Right?
I mean, that, you know, that's an aufhebung from those kinds of positions, you know?
Right.
But appearance is the arising and passing away that constitutes the actuality and the movement and the life of truth.
Right?
Like, that's, truth is appearance.
I mean, that's the thesis.
Yeah.
That's a nice, concise little...
It is, after all, the Phenomenology of Spirit.
I mean, that's what it is.
I mean, there's another good, yeah, there's another good little, I'm not getting it exactly right, but it's like, the only thing behind, it's a Hegel quote,
the only thing behind appearances are what we put there, or like, you know, so it's like, it is a phenomenology.
And I feel like that's something that people also forget when we read this.
It's like, I mean, he makes, he's also written A Philosophy of Nature, so don't get me wrong, he's expanded beyond the simple Phenomenology of Spirit.
But all of this is, at a base level, incorporating the movement of subjectivity into various discourses that have suppressed that, you know?
But that's where, like, you know, if you tell the story that Nathaniel just told, it's like, it's fucking 2,000 years for one goddamn mouth hay bong.
Like, one, you know?
It's like, we've got semblance or appearance, and we've got, you know, and rhetoric, or we've got, you know, over here, truth, knowledge, philosophy.
And it took motherfucking 1,800 years to say, hey, maybe we don't have to choose.
Right, right.
Now, again, still, I would say, it's still the movement of truth.
Like, why does it have to be, I mean, like, my response to this would be, I mean, why does the arising and passing away that is appearance have to constitute the movement of truth?
Like, why, the payoff is always going to be on the side of truth, even when its content is now the realm of appearance.
But still, you're still playing the same kind of, the truth game, right?
It's just that now truth is mobile and not propositional, as opposed to just saying, it's just mobile and, you know, it's just mobile.
You know, there's, and I would be, well, I mean, my inclination is much more for coding that way.
It's like, well, look, truth is clearly propositional because that's how it's been taken for the most part.
Right, like, for the most, in other words, it's a rhetorical way of saying, truth is not some God term just handed down.
Truth is how people use it.
And how people have used it is in that propositional sense.
So, rather than fighting against that propositional sense, just say, like, you know.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, the least you can say is that Hegel's truth is not Aristotle's truth.
So, I mean, as long as we're not saying that Hegel is, like, some sort of fundamentalist,
where there is a substrate beneath the appearance that can be, like, riven out by the dialectic,
that's not the case.
Because he's still committed to truth, I think, almost just on a logical, like, level.
Well, I think you're right.
I think, in fact, that was one of the thoughts that I had.
It's like, fuck, I probably feel like I need to go read the Science of Logic, although I
think I would probably hate that.
But, nevertheless, no, I think you're right.
It is a logical, a commitment to a logic where truth has to be the upshot.
But, yeah, you're right.
There's no substrate beneath appearance.
He's trying to say, how do you think the coming to be and passing away?
Like, that's it.
Now, and again, I still think, I mean, I think I said this a couple of meetings ago,
but, like, I still think that's a book I want to read, which is, any thinker of any note
today is a process thinker, period.
But there are very different ways of thinking process.
And now let's try to parse out the ways in which someone like Deleuze is different than
someone like Zizek, for example.
And not because of one is committed to truth and the other one is secretly hiding in a pit.
No.
This is where, for me, style, it's like, these are different styles.
So, the proper name Žižek and the proper name Deleuze, these are stylistic differences.
The stylistic differences are really fucking substantive, right?
They're really fucking important.
They matter a great deal.
But that's what they are.
They're just ways of thinking movement.
They're both thinkers of movement, you know.
And they're both thinkers of fucking negation and affirmation.
Like, you can't not be.
It's just a question of how they operate and which are the generating principles, right?
Like, the whole team negation versus team, you know.
So, and again, the thing that I've always liked, I mean, the thing that I always like
about Zizek is that he's funny.
Like, because that's always, for me, one of the things, like, there ain't a fucking thing
funny in this book, right?
There's not even, you know, so, and that sense of seriousness, and that's always been one
of the things for me that I attach to, a thinking of negation coming from Nietzsche is that sense
of laughter, right?
Like, really, as a sort of tonal, stylistic, whatever, dimension of, it's not an extrinsic.
It's not like, oh, occasionally they make jokes.
It's that the thinking itself is funny, you know, or has a comedic side to it or whatever
the fuck that means.
And Zizek's like that, right?
Like, Zizek is funny, you know?
Yeah.
Zizek is funny.
I mean, he's so strange, because there's nobody that really writes like that, or that even
really tries to, like, both commit to the seriousness of a thinker like Hegel.
Like, he'll get in the weeds with this stuff, and there won't be a funny section for maybe
even an entire chapter, but then he'll tell some super raunchy joke, like, in the middle
of something, and it, like, breaks it all up.
I mean, I don't know.
It's just weird, like, trying to locate that style in a, you know, genre of styles that
seems to be more committed to that serious tone.
That's right.
To the seriousness.
So Zizek, to me, is really very much the exception in that lineage, because...
I mean, I don't mind seriousness.
It's just, obviously, it can get boring, eventually.
Yeah.
Like, Hegel's seriousness, I think, ironically, there's levity when it gets even darker.
So, like, when he starts...
Like, he engages in some poetic imagery, like, here and there, which I wanted to just bring
up to you guys.
Yeah.
I think it is at the bottom...
Not the painter who's red and black.
Yeah.
There was another...
Red and green, I guess it was.
Okay, so this is 52.
It's just, like, such a kind of grotesque, like, invocation of the understanding.
It's right at the...
This is the first sentence of 52.
Yeah, yeah.
I noted that as well.
I was like, damn, this is intense.
Yeah, I'm just like, why is this so intense?
Like, why does it need to be written this way?
But that, to me, is almost like...
That's where the levity...
The levity in Hegel is when he goes to this crazy, weird, dark image.
That's brutality of, like, it's being flayed and seeing its skin wrapped around a lifeless
knowledge of its conceits and its conceits, right?
Yeah, it's like, huh.
It's a brutality.
It doesn't seem...
There's nothing like...
Yeah, go ahead.
Tell me what you think of this little bit on 48, because I thought it was hilarious,
but I genuinely, because I can't...
I want to believe that maybe there's a little bit of self-reflection here, but I'm also doubting
it.
So this is on 48, like, one, two, three, four, five, six.
Let's say, like, seven lines down, after he's finished talking about logic and, like, we
have to attend to the method of this movement.
If this comment sounds boastful or revolutionary, and I am far from adopting such a tone, it
should be noted that the current opinion, like, he has to see that, right?
Yeah.
He has to see that.
That's because he's done nothing but this.
That's all he's done, is boasting about how this is the end of fucking history.
Yeah.
Like, he is the revolutionary point of history.
Right.
Right?
I mean, there has to be some.
Imagine if he's giving a lecture.
He has to, like, wink, right?
Maybe?
Eventually.
There have to be moments, I think.
But any, like, if you want to consider him either a savant or there's some sort of genius
going on, right?
I mean, you have to admit that.
But most people like that, there's also a level of delusion, right?
I mean, if you look, I mean, again, I don't want to, I don't know why I'm bringing up Kanye
West, but, like, at least when he was at his creative, like, peak, right, there's, what
is it, what is driving that to some extent is delusion and not self-awareness.
So the greatness that he was able to achieve was because he was, like, blind to his own
faults and deficiencies and was simply, like, going after something that seemed unachievable.
I think maybe, maybe you could give Hegel a similar analysis there, where, like, the impetus
It's really, yeah, it's really interesting, though, the extent to which what we can locate
at the comedic is so dependent on an authorial intention, like, it's so totally, in other
words, like, maybe the comedic is what becomes super dark and is just motherfucking dark and
bleak, right?
Like, why do we have to have a notion of, well, he was, that was a kind of tongue-in-cheek
bleakness.
It's like, no, no, no, that's motherfucking bleakness.
So then you get into the question of what's the comedic and tragic, and we get back into
those polls.
But those are poles that are worth messing up, too, right?
I mean, insofar as, like, yeah, like, I mean, it's interesting because I like the seriousness,
but I also like the smart-ass elements that pull me out, that pull me out of the seriousness
so that I'm not just living in that totally serious.
And I agree with you, Nate.
Passages, like, the one that you mentioned, because I marked it, I was, it was kind of
like a, it was fun, right?
Like, whether or not it was tongue-in-cheek or comedic, in some ways is kind of secondary,
because what it was, was something other than simply the systematic delineation of the movement
of spirit.
Well, and it was the intensification of that to its own, like, brain point, right?
I think of the Deleuze versions of irony and comedy.
And comedy, yeah.
Right?
Like, the movement of irony of, like, the self, perpetually self-undoing itself, but the
comedy movement of taking itself to the point of its own undoing, which sounds a whole lot
like, you know, just, like, talking about making mathematical formula seem alive by filleting
skin and wrapping them around them.
Right.
You said, "Don't dirty the gun."
Don't get the gun dirty.
All right.
Can we pause on that short bit again, though?
So, at 52, does it, does your translation start with the excellent?
Yeah.
What is your saying?
It's a weird subject with that verb.
Or that, with that sentence.
Yeah, so the, the excellent not only cannot escape the fate of being deprived of life and
spirit, of being flayed and then seeing its skin wrapped around lifeless knowing, and that
lifeless knowing's vanity.
So, I was just wondering why the introduction of this, of the excellent, first of all, because
I don't think we've seen that.
I had to go back, I had to go back for that.
No, no, no.
I mean, I had the same problem, because I was like, the excellent, where did that, so, I
mean, all I'm presuming is that, insofar as it's a critique, it's like, even good ideas
have to go through this process.
Right, right, right.
I mean, that's all that I took it to mean, but I don't, the, the, the particular terminology
of the excellent, I don't, it didn't.
My guess is, this is just from, I think I read it in Zizek, it might be a parallel with,
like, reason or self-consciousness.
So, the excellent would be, like, a term for that step beyond the understanding.
So, but, I mean, this points to what we were talking about earlier, where it's like, that
tension between the understanding and its supposed sublation in reason.
It's like, it's not, you don't just get to go past it, right?
So, if, if that is a term for reason, it can't escape the fate of being.
It's got, it's got to be flayed, and it's got to have this lifeless shit, like, that's,
that's the game, right?
Like, it's just going to go down that road.
And earlier, that was a good thing.
Now, it's like, this horrific thing.
But, rather, you know, we recognize, even in this fate, the power that the excellent exercises
over the hearts, if not over the minds.
In other words, like, that's closer to the sense certainty side of things than it is to,
so, I mean, in this sense, and, I mean, this is a, this is a conclusion that I kind of agree
with, is, like, there's actually very little thinking in the world.
Like, it's just not something that happens for us very often.
Like, in terms of the requirements that he's establishing for thinking, most human beings,
like, literally never think, right?
In this sense, you know?
And even those of us who fancy ourselves thinkers, we don't think a lot.
We don't think all the time.
In fact, it's really fucking rare and hard to think.
When you kind of just happen upon it.
Like, you're like, oh, all of a sudden I'm thinking.
Just out of nowhere, I'm actually thinking.
Thinking happens.
That's, I mean, that's where you get, like, it's a weird idealism then, right?
Like, I mean, it's not like the sort of Berkeley version of, like, it's just like the thinking
substance that's not inside of a human.
But, I mean, it's a very weird, like, yeah, thinking happens in the sense of shit happens.
Right?
Like, that middle voice thing that Heidegger's big on.
Right.
And that's also a Deleuzian sentiment, too.
Yeah, no, I know.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I know this is my experience, and I always introduce my classes.
It's like, we're going to presume that thinking is very difficult and rarely happens.
But there's a lot of just, like, preparatory work for it.
Like, really, I feel like the only work that I do for thinking, like, I never do the thinking.
I mean, it's only about staging the, creating the conditions of possibility for new connections
to come out.
And then once, you know, in those rare occasions where some new connection comes about, then
suddenly, like, everything, it's like a gestalt movement.
And, you know, there's just, like, this whole new image that has to be, or this whole new
terrain that, you know, has to be explored.
And that's just, like, almost grunt work, right?
Almost, yeah.
But that's the example that he gave when he was using the triangle, and he was going through
the issue of the proof of the triangle and how it's completely removed from actuality
and whatnot.
And the thing that kept occurring to me was, what about the guy who discovered, whoever
was at Archimedes, I don't know who discovered the 180 degrees or whatever, the right triangle.
A squared, E squared equals C squared, whoever it was.
But there was the moment of discovery of the right angle and the lengths of sides.
That moment seems like it was a moment of thinking.
Everything in history involving triangles since then hasn't been that, right?
It has been the sort of demonstration of the proof, the playing out of the proof, the, you
know.
So, but that's to your point, Nathaniel, of, like, there was, in terms of triangles and
the history, there was a moment of thinking that happened for somebody, Pythagoras, Archimedes,
whoever the fuck it was, and then all of the rest of triangles' history has not involved
thinking, right?
Like, it's just been the playing out of that one moment.
For absolute spirit, right?
Right, right.
But then there's the, because, you know, he's got the two levels of understanding, and
so, like, that, like, every, you know, we were talking about, everyone has to, spirit
might, on the scale of A to Z, spirit might be an M, but I'm more like a D.
Like, I still have to go through the activity of thinking, you know, that thing.
But it is still a repetition of something.
But you don't, but in a sense, I mean, that's where I think he's right, is that, like, most
people don't, right?
Like, you don't have to really, you don't have to, I mean, even, even, I mean, we're
talking about geometry here.
Even when you took your high school geometry class, you didn't learn, you didn't think
about A squared plus B squared equals C squared.
All you did was memorize that rule and apply it in particular situations.
You never had to derive that rule.
You know, you never had to think in the sense of developing a connection that hadn't been
there before.
Well, it doesn't become, you know, I can put, like, this is the, the, the, the two repetitions
that drive Plato batty, right?
That, you know, I can repeat to you, you know, all of these correct statements, all these true
beliefs about the right triangle, but that doesn't mean that I have a living understanding that
would allow me to manipulate it in different directions.
And I can look at it from 15 different angles and see them all like I, you know, it's
impossible to determine the difference from.
It's the desire to, so, but that's what, that's what Hegel, I think, shares with Plato is
the, is the desire to separate the two repetitions.
Now, he's not necessarily saying one is, you know, like better than, but one is like, there's
a true repetition and Deleuze fucking, I mean, that's Deleuze's Difference in Repetition,
right?
There is the abstract repetition of generality and then there's true, true repetition, right?
And, and so that, that desire to distinguish between, like, sometimes it's the false movement
of habit, sometimes something else happens, you know?
Right.
Well, this, this is something I can't, I don't know exactly the details of the argument, but
in Žižek's long ass book on Hegel, that's something that he sort of concedes to Deleuze
in a way, where it's like Hegel, one of the critiques of Hegel that he basically buys is
that he can't think pure repetition.
And so that's something that Deleuze was able to access.
That's something that even, I think, Lacan, Žižek argues, was able to access in some way.
But for Hegel, pure repetition without sublation is not possible.
Um, I don't know anything else beyond that, but I remember reading that in that, yeah.
Well, because the repetition has to be mediated, right?
Like, the truth of the, the truth of the right triangle has to then be mediated within the
understanding, but the understand, the repet, the repeated understanding has to be living,
right?
It can't just be the dead propositions that one has memorized.
Like, I don't know about you all, but this is why I hated math in high school, because
I felt like all I was being asked to do was memorize formula and then apply them.
And I didn't understand, like, I've always been someone that has to understand the rationale
of the thing, and, like, that just was not the important part of it.
Right, what can I do with it?
Like, we can't do anything with it besides get this test right, you know?
There's no point.
Well, it's not even that.
You can do plenty of things.
Like, I can just, you know, like, monkey repeat a bunch of formula and build a bridge,
right?
From, but that doesn't mean I understand, you know, the, the, you know, to take on.
But that was, see, I got, I got totally spoiled on that, and this is a, one of my major early
intellectual influences was, like, my, I had the AP math classes were all the same teacher,
and I was in those, and, and his name was Steve Sorkin, and he, he always, his whole
thing was, uh, sheer memorization is for fucking monkeys, like, you guys have to learn these
things, and our final, the final exams, they were notorious, because, and this was a long
time then, it doesn't sound like a lot then, but you'd come in, and there would be one question,
just one question, and it would be a fairly simple looking diagram, this is geometry, fairly
simple looking diagrams, like, find this angle, and that was it, that was the whole final
exam, and it would take six hours, I mean, no joke, because he had designed these questions
so that there were about 20 different pathways that you could follow, and they all went, you know,
to certain, you know, some of them went 10 steps deep before you realized dead end, some of them
went two steps before dead end, but you had to go through a bunch of them in order to figure out,
now, the other side is, and this never happened to me, but it did happen to people I know, you could
hit on the right one, just sheerly accidentally, and you'd be done with the exam in 10 minutes,
and it did happen for people, like, they signed, and they're like, I'm done, I got it, 10 minutes in,
and everybody else is there for hours, like, ordering pizzas in and shit, but that was his whole
thing, was, it's not enough to just memorize, like, yeah, you have to do that, you've got to memorize the
stuff, but you have to understand how these things operate, and you have, you know, you have to
exhibit, so, so fortunately for me, math was not that grunt, kind of grunt process at all, it was
totally creative, problem-solving, uh, approach to learning. This was the issue for me with, with math
and with music when I first started learning music, because I, I was like, my grandma was, like, a
classically trained, uh, pianist, and toured the country, and was amazing, but she taught me,
like, classically, which is basically, you memorize pieces, so I, I learned a bunch of these pieces when
I was, like, 10 or 11, did a few recitals, but I wasn't able or even encouraged to create anything
on my own, so I just, I just completely lost interest. It was, it wasn't only till I picked
it back up when I was, like, 18 in college, and, and I'd just basically forgotten everything and
relearned it, started making my own shit that I was able to, like, I like building stuff,
but if I don't have the route or the means to do that with this information, I, I kind
of get lost, you know, and so I don't think you necessarily, oh, go ahead, finish up me,
sorry. I was just, I was just gonna say, like, because we were saying, you were saying earlier
how, like, you know, Pythagoras or whoever invented the theory of the right triangle, and
then everything else was a repetition of that. I also, I mean, just to qualify that, I don't
think you have to reinvent the wheel every time in order to build something useful either,
like, this is another music thing, but, like, I, I don't have any knowledge about, like,
the, the specifics of engineering where, like, you're actually building the software and the
instruments. I simply use it and, like, build stuff that's already made, you know what I mean?
And I, I would like to think that I can make stuff that's, like, I don't know, sometimes compelling,
but I'm not inventing the thing, right? Somebody else had to do all that work for me to use the
computer and the software and the different synthesizers, so I'm, like, sort of on the front
end developer or whatever, like, I'm on the surface of everything, but I, I think that's, so in a sense,
I'm just repeating the triangle. Well, and that, and that's, but that's also where the people that
we consider, I mean, I, you know, obviously in a little bit of a Van Halen mode for the last,
you know, month or so, but I mean, you know, the guys who are kind of great musicians, they're the
ones who remake the technology too, right? They don't simply use the technology to make sounds that
we, in combinations of sounds we haven't heard before, but, you know, Van Halen is an example of that,
like, whatever one thinks of Eddie Van Halen and the whole rock god thing, which I'm glad it's
passed and, you know, all those things, but nevertheless, like, the guy reinvented the
fucking guitar, like, which is just mind-blowing when you consider how many guitarists had existed
before him. Or someone like Hendrix, you know. Hendrix, right, same kind of thing, like, those guys who
are the, the geniuses, they go back into the equivalent of the software, the interface, and start
tinkering with that shit. Like, you know, the real musicians are just, I remember hearing stories
from Storr of R.E.M. finishing up their Automatic, one of the albums, and, and Michael Stipe, like,
after 16 hours straight of, like, you know, he pulls away, he's like, if I, if I move one more
fucking electron around on this board, I'm gonna lose my fucking mind, and he has to, you know,
he has to go away for a few days, because he's so immersed in the technology of the sound
board. This isn't about musical instruments, this is about the whole recording operation,
so yeah, yeah.
It's amazing to me how quickly we've kind of, this discourse has shifted into a, very much
sort of, like, a humanist discourse of, like, subject-object, where repetition only happens,
like, mediated through the subject, and it is the subject that then has, like, this sort
of abstracted power to be able to, like, it isn't, it's now no long, it's a capacity rather
than a repetition, right?
Right.
Where, I mean, on the one hand, I absolutely, like, not all repetitions are made the same,
and the kind of, like, you know, repetition of something within the consciousness might
be different than other kinds of repetitions, but it would, it'd be interesting to sort of
now, like, go back and think about, you know, try to imagine this alone, a strata that doesn't
think about these as true or false repetitions, and that, like, you know, the monkey repetition
now does something, like, it, the monkey repetition is still a repetition that is no more or less
true or false.
That's where, yeah, that's, that's where I want to say, you know, even with difference
in repetition, you know, my aversion has always been to that first sentence, you know, his aversion
to generality and the concept, and it's like, that has to do something too, man, I mean, that
has to be, you know, like, you could ask the question, it's like, what is this style of repetition
that enables a blade of grass to photosynthesize, right?
There, there had to have been a lot of false turns, right?
There had to have been a whole lot of blades of grass, or the equivalent thereof, that didn't,
you know, that didn't photosynthesize, and something had to happen that enabled that photosynthesis,
and that to me is, it's no different than that, that's, he's the Eddie Van Halen of grass,
right?
Or the Hendrix, or whatever, like, something was able to transform, or the, you know, symbiogenesis,
right, is my, my example.
See, I take that first line a little bit different, I mean, I don't, I don't see a discordance between
what is philosophy and difference in repetition in that sense, because I, I think in both of
them, there, there still is not repetition within generality, right?
Because that would be, you know, it would be the repetition of one transcendent model of,
say, photosynthesis, that then gets repeated across all of its instances, but you'd have
to say that photosynthesis isn't photosynthesis isn't photosynthesis, and the repetition of
any one of these things, like, the true repetition of it isn't that it modeled, it took something
else as its model, and then repeated it, it's that this, like, the singularity of this intersection
or constellation of forces now exerts its force, and forces response to it, and it's that
force, like, it's the exertion of the force and the force of the response to it, that is
the repetition itself.
So, I mean, that's where, that's where something natural, like graphs and photosynthesis, is
actually an easier and better example than a person learning, because a person learning
can be easily misunderstood, so it's, it's better to be like, okay, the singularity of
the encounter is what produced the necessity of what we now call photosynthesis along a series
of differential repetitions.
So, let's, can we go back and then try to re-articulate, you know, the, like, the understanding
of the right triangle, because I, I think it would look something like this, that, you know,
rather than, you know, I have a, a copy of Pythagoras's or Euclid's theorem in my head,
and, like, I'm able, it's, rather...
It was Euclid, Euclid, that's who it was, it was fucking Euclid.
Shout out to Steve Sorkin, man, he taught me well.
Let's make sure, make sure that makes the actual episode.
Yeah, because the Pythagorean theorem is about finding the hypotenome, but finding the lengths
of, of the, of the, the lines of the triangle, but I think it's Euclid.
All right.
Anyway, um, but anyway, it's more that, that, like, think about the myriad of repetitions
that could strike you at a particular time that sort of, like, lodges different connections
together that allows you to now navigate a right triangle like you weren't able to before.
It's not a capacity that you can deploy or not deploy.
It's a set of relations that gets snapped into place.
And by the way, just because, you know, like, it doesn't mean that all of them are snapped
into, like, it doesn't mean that there is a right way of snapping them into place and
a wrong way of snapping them into place.
It's like, you know, I, when it snaps into place for me, it might open up pathways that
allow me to think about some other fucking thing totally differently when it happens for
Right.
Instead of photosynthesis, it could have been chemical synthesis of, of oxygen, which would
have produced all different kinds of life forms.
It just happened the way that it happened.
Yeah.
Exactly.
That it's, yeah, that, that, that, that, like, like, how do we think learning without
fidelity?
You know, that, I think that's sort of like, what's that question here?
Right.
And I, I mean, I think the, the attention to those contingencies is, is precisely what
Hegel's at least trying to get at with his complication of the mathematical thinking.
And I think it directly prefigures, or at least this is Žižek's argument, uh, it direct, it
prefigures almost directly like the, the quantum sort of approach with Niels Bohr or even Heisenberg,
you know, where you're, the contingencies that were previously suppressed.
You want to go after Barad, I know what's driving this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The contingencies that were previously, you know, suppressed by Einstein or whoever were
then directly incorporated into the quantum theoretical system by Niels Bohr.
Into the system rather than being extrinsic, yeah.
Right.
And of course you're not going to be able to fully assimilate those contingencies, but
Well, you can't assimilate all contingency, that's what makes it contingency.
That's the definition, right.
But, uh, that, I mean, that approach had never been seen before, right?
I mean, at least until Hegel, right, at this nation phenomenological stage, and then until
Niels Bohr, who I think is like the Hegelian theoretical physicist, uh, sort of, I think,
I mean, I, I don't know, at least it seemed like it was, that approach reflects what you
were talking about, Nathaniel, with the, with the attention to the relations that produces
your either capacity to learn or to know or whatever, you know?
I, I, I like that.
I mean, I, I, that's good.
I mean, because it provides an explanation for, you know, both the necessity of the separation,
but the separation is always, the separation of the two repetitions, but it's always provisional.
And, um, so like, you know, both repetitions are going to go down different kinds of paths,
but you don't know what that path's going to be until there are subsequent repetitions.
Well, what I like about it is it allows you to think the sort of fidelity repetition as
a prompt for producing real repetition, right?
And rather than think about the, the, the fact that, you know, the fidelity repetition is
never going to actually be faithful and therefore there's a lack or a failure.
Everything's a failure.
Right.
But no, it's just like, here's one style of provoking true repetitions.
Try to be faithful.
Right.
Exactly.
Because you can't be, you know, and, and, and by the way, that's not a failure.
It's, and it's not a lack of totality, but that's where I feel like you got to, I guess
it's just important to me still that you lose the metaphorics of negation, lack unity, you
know, all of like that.
You start, that's where, I mean, multiplicity becomes, I guess, even more important in that
regard in terms of if the investment is in provoking in this thinking, you need a self-identity
in order to other, right?
In order, like you have to have a stable relatively, right?
Like it's not stable, stable.
It's not Cartesian.
It's not a monad, right?
Like, but you have to have a relatively stable, the self-identity, his stuff on self-identity
In here is really good because where he, he will both say self-identity is a thing.
And then he'll say, but self-identity itself is already constituted by the very movement
that we're talking about.
So you have to have a self-identity in order to have another.
And in that case, it looks like the other is coming from outside.
I could probably find this passage that I'm, and rather than try to, you know, paraphrase.
Well, he talks about absolute identity as something that's dead.
Oh, so this is on, this is the, here we have a, in 55, there's a paragraph break in our translation
for the last paragraph of 55.
For us, it begins precisely because existence is defined as species, as a simple thought,
news, simplicity, as substance.
But on account of its simplicity or self-identity, it appears fixed and enduring.
But this self-identity is no less negativity.
Therefore, its fixed existence passes over into its dissolution.
Dissolution, in this case, means encountering alterity, right?
Right.
The determinateness seems, at first, to be due entirely to the fact that it is related
to an other.
In other words, what gives you this notion of an other is the belief in self-identity.
And its movement seems imposed on it by an alien power.
But having its otherness within itself and being self-moving, again, with all the provisions
around self-moving that we began with, is just what is involved in the simplicity of thinking
itself.
So, I mean, I take that to be exactly that point, is that there's a creation of a, what
we would call, provisional self-identity, which allows otherness to impact it, or allows
contingency to impact it.
So, this is like, in biology, this is autopoiesis, you know, that you have to have a sense of a
cell as a self-identical entity before you can think about, you know, cells interacting with
each other to become an organism, you know, or something like that.
So, and that's the thing, let's be honest, that's the thing that all the eco and network
people just don't get, right?
Because they're just all about assembling cells together.
That's where, to me, there's no critique of identity just by saying there's a lot of
them, you know?
Yeah.
I mean, there's no problematizing of the function of identity just by saying, hey, look, you're
made up of an ecology.
Or, hey, you know, you're not critiquing individuality by saying, I'm part of an ecology, which I think
a lot of people think you are.
And they're like, no, you're just saying there's more nodes in this system than just one.
But that doesn't do anything to the logic of self-identity unless you do what he's doing
here.
Right, and I think that also, I mean, it complicates at least a little bit Barad's thesis, like
her little slogan that it's relations before relata, you know?
Right.
Well, it's like when you take autopoiesis, it's like, no, I mean, it's at least both, you
have to have both.
You have both at the same time.
Right, yeah, there's relata before relations just as there are relations before relata,
you know?
Right, and that really is, that's the hard thing to think is, because I mean, I was always
skeptical of autopoiesis for that reason, is because it was like, you know,
well, we need self-identity so we can have otherness and any kind of movement at all.
And I was always skeptical of that, because, but then I read a really interesting article,
this is way back in grad school, of like, well, autopoiesis is really exopoiesis or allopoiesis.
Because, you know, the auto that comes to be auto is already in relationship to, it has
to be in relationship to an outside.
So it's a question of, partly of emphasis, right, in terms of, but also, you know, as
you're pointing out, Nate, like, you have to start to then think the simultaneity of the
auto and the aloe in that regard, and stop with the origin question of self-other, right?
Like, so that's, so in that sense, you would say, Levinas doesn't go far enough, right?
Because he's just saying, okay, the other is the condition of the emergence of the eye.
And it's like, well, all you're doing is kind of, in my world, like flipping the dialectical
coin, like what's really necessary is to think the simultaneity of those.
you